distinguished guests
dear friends when the hydrogen council
was launched in davos
four years ago it was the first global
initiative of its kind
and you understood that hydrogen
should have a central place in the
transition to climate neutrality
and you called on policy makers to do
their part
you were ahead of the times
today the crucial role of hydrogen is
widely recognized
including by the european green deal
which we launched
just over a year ago clean hydrogen
is a perfect means towards our goal of
climate neutrality
it can power heavy industries
propel our cars our trucks and our
planes
it can store seasonal energy or heat up
our homes and all of this with almost
zero emissions so
clean hydrogen demonstrates that we can
reconcile
our economy with the health of our
planet
and this is precisely the spirit of the
european green deal
our hydrogen strategy makes hydrogen a
key asset
for the european green deal the focus in
the strategy
is on clean hydrogen produced from
renewable energy sources
low carbon hydrogen can be part of the
transition
but only renewable hydrogen will bring
us to climate neutrality
we also want to make clean hydrogen the
best
choice in economic terms and the good
news is
with enough commitment we can reach the
tipping point
where clean hydrogen becomes more
competitive
than its alternatives with the right
investment
and the right policies clean hydrogen
can go mainstream
and this will create new markets for
europe new economies of scale
new business opportunities we
aim at an annual production capacity
for renewable hydrogen of 1 million
tons by 2024 and
10 million tons by 2030
it is an ambitious yet realistic goal
we can achieve it if we join forces
public and private sector all together
today i would like to tell you what the
european union is doing in concrete
let me focus on four practical actions
first we have set clear targets
for cutting our emissions and made them
legally binding
we want to cut our emissions by at least
55
by 2030 on the way to climate neutrality
by 2050
and this is something you have been
asking for
for years clear credible
and certain targets to give industry the
predictability
you need to plan your investment
second we are investing in clean
hydrogen like
never before our investment plan called
next generation eu is worth 750 billion
euros
over one-third of this will finance the
goals
set in the european green deal including
unclean hydrogen for instance we want to
create hydrogen valleys
and hydrogen islands we want to have
hydrogen produced
where it is most economical
and then builds strong distribution
grids
to transport it where it is needed a
true
european clean hydrogen market
with hydrogen priced in euros
so we have asked member states to
identify the right
places for this places
where clean hydrogen creates growth and
jobs
in full respect of the environment
third we are changing the rules of the
game
to facilitate the deployment of clean
hydrogen
we are well aware of the regulatory
obstacles you
face in your daily work european
energy regulations were written at a
time
when hydrogen was less part of the
picture
so we are changing them for instance
last month
we proposed a revised regulation
on the trans-european networks for
energy
with it we will facilitate a quick
integration of hydrogen in our energy
system of the future
and fourth we have created a new
alliance with the private sector
our success will depend entirely
on cooperation with companies like yours
and this is why we have launched the
european clean
hydrogen alliance and i'm glad
that over 1 000 companies have already
joined it
now let me invite those of you who are
based in the european union
to also join and endorse its objectives
through the alliance we want to look at
the entire
hydrogen value chain from production to
distribution
from seasonal storage to refueling
stations
from heavy industries to all areas of
mobility
together we can synchronize
investments in all these sectors
bringing together demand and supply
at european and even international scale
we can activate a self-feeding circle
that cuts production costs while
boosting
demand and in this way
we can reach our goals starting with the
production of
one million tons of renewable hydrogen
by 2024.
ladies and gentlemen your contribution
will be crucial
you hold the key to the successful
transition to clean hydrogen
because the final investment decisions
are for the private sector to take
and these decisions need to be taken
right now
we must achieve climate neutrality by
2050
there will be no extra time no second
chance
there are four billion tons of co2
that still separate us from our goal
four billion tons of co2
that we still produce every single year
here in the european union
and to get rid of them we need bold
decisions
we need to fully decarbonize hydrogen
production
we need out-of-the-box solutions to
transform
how we produce how we heat and how we
travel
and i know that many of you have already
embarked
in this transformation thanks to you
hydrogen aircrafts clean steel
and hydrogen trucks are not science
fiction any longer
you made this a reality
in the coming years we will need all
your ingenuity
and entrepreneurial spirit on my
side i can assure you that europe is
serious about clean hydrogen
clean hydrogen is part of our future
and you will find in the european union
a reliable partner
and an ally on the path towards climate
neutrality
2050 is not that far away
but the future has already begun we need
your leadership
and your support thank you very much for
that